- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is be yourself.
Over to you, Freddy Mercury.
(rooster cock-a-doodle-doos)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- I'd like to feel that
after all these years,
I'm myself at every given point.
When I'm onstage,
that's Freddy Mercury.
When I'm offstage,
I'm Freddy Mercury.
And that's the only way to be,
I mean I don't,
the days have gone where
I actually felt that
when I was onstage,
when I came off I still
had to sort of portray
that Freddy Mercury image
because of other people.
I used to do that before
because you have to grow up
and you have to understand,
you have to really come
to grips with success.
And over the years I found
out that you can become
a very, very lonely person
if you have to do that,
and I'm not afraid when I come offstage
to actually be myself.
- So this is a message I've been hearing
more and more and more on the channel
from the famous entrepreneurs
that I've been paying attention to,
and I think it's so important.
I think you have to be yourself
because everybody else is taken.
You're not going to have success
being a copy of somebody else.
I remember watching a video of Jay-Z,
Warren Buffet and the guy from Forbes.
And he was asking Jay-Z,
"Do you ever get intimidated
being around Warren Buffet
"and being around these guys in suits?
"You know, you walk into a boardroom,
"you're from the streets,
"do you ever get intimidated?"
And he's like, "No."
They're like, "Why not?"
And he said, "Because I'm myself.
"Wherever I go, I'm myself."
And there's so much
confidence that that brings
when you're not trying
to be somebody else,
that when you go into any situation,
any room,
whether it's super outside
your comfort zone or not,
that you have the confidence
that you are awesome
and you bring that everywhere you go.
And what often happens
when you're first trying
to discover yourself,
think at the start of any process,
you look up to people,
you model success, right?
You learn from them,
you want to be the next Steve Jobs
so you copy some of the things from him.
At some point you have to figure out,
okay, I'm going to not
be the next Steve Jobs
but I'm going to be the best me
and I'm going to pull different pieces
to allow that to happen.
And when you start experimenting,
a lot of times what happens
is you go backwards.
This is what happened actually
at that Trinidad salsa.
You know, I'm encouraging
all my instructors
that you need to discover yourself.
This is how I teach it,
this is how you know,
somebody else may teach it.
You have to teach the same
moves that come out in class,
but the way you teach it,
the stories you tell,
the energy and vibe that you
bring has to be different
because you can't be me.
You can have the same message if you want,
if that's something that you believe in,
but even that,
how you deliver it,
how you execute it,
the vibe you bring will be different.
If you try to be me,
you're always going to fail.
You're always going to fall
short of what you can do
because you're not
actually being yourself,
you're being a copy of somebody else.
And so, at the start to
figure out what it is
that you stand for and
your one word helps you
with that process,
understand what you stand for,
and then start applying some
ideas into your business,
into your life.
I want to add more believe to my life.
What does that look like?
What does that look like in my videos,
what does that look like
in my relationships?
And at the start it may not work.
You may try something and it doesn't work.
And you have to experiment
and have the confidence and the
courage that you are awesome
and you're going to figure it out,
and that the only way
you are going to win,
the only way,
the game that you're playing in life,
in business,
the only way you're going to
win is if you go all in on you.
On the awesomeness that is you,
believe that what you have inside you
is special and amazing
and start applying it.
Radical self expression in
whatever way that comes out.
It's the only way you're going to win.
Stop just trying to copy somebody else,
go all in on you.
So the question of the day today
is I'd love to hear a story
of how you went all in on yourself.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kevin Lee,
Kevin, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word,
I really, really appreciate the support,
it means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- Don't become like a cult,
like don't just like me.
Be a fan of everyone.
You can like Rihanna's
music and mine and Gaga's,
it's okay.
You don't have to be like,
"I'm a Jessie J. Fan (growls)."
(laughter)
You know.
My mom and dad would never
let me put posters on the wall
because they were like,
"Be you, be inspired,
"but don't become anyone else."
Which is why I think as an
artist I wasn't very, very,
the one thing that I was very proud of
was when I first came out that
no one compared me to anyone.
I think you can tell when someone's
idolized somebody sometimes.
And I think it's good to be inspired,
but don't become somebody.
Be yourself.
Just always be yourself.
Always.
Whatever people say about you,
whatever people believe...
That is true, that isn't about you,
trust me,
life is not worth living
feeling sad and down and lonely.
Just always be true to who you are.
- I was always the class clown,
I know it's kind of weird and shitty,
and it's kind of like,
I've always been an outcast
because they never felt me.
I know we're the outcasts,
I mean if you listen to the music,
or just us in general,
like you met me in person,
I'm just serious now,
but I'm always jumping around.
I'm surprised I sat down still this time.
We've always been outcasts,
and it's kind of cool
because this is what's
going to make us great in the future.
At the end of the day,
throughout all the jokes
and bullshit or whatever,
just always be yourself,
that's the one thing that I'm like,
just do it.
That's what I try to tell people,
just to do what they want.
And that's why at the end of the day,
I'm always going to make
the music I want to make.
Like, people get so caught up
in like making their first album,
like Basser like was pretty successful
and people are like,
"Oh shit, I hope you make
something like that."
But, I can't.
It's regression,
I'm in a whole different mindset.
I'm having a,
I wasn't having that shit a year ago,
so I'm going to make the
music that I want to make now,
that sounds cool to me.
Who knows,
I might end up doing
coke and be a drug addict
two years from now and making
some off the wall music.
At the end of the day,
I'm going to fight it,
and I think that's one
of the main reasons why
people love us,
because we do what we want.
- It goes back to a bit of
what Warren was saying as well,
like it's the discipline as well.
The discipline to not get
caught up in the moment.
You know, music is like stocks, too,
you know,
there's the hot thing of the moment.
You know, there's this hot electro sound
or the hot auto tuned voice
or the hot whatever,
whatever is new and exciting.
And you know, you know,
people tend to make emotional
decisions based on that,
they don't stick with what they know.
This is why I am,
you know, this is what I do.
And then they you know,
jump on this next hot thing and you know,
it's not for you.
So, for me,
just having the discipline
and having the confidence
in who I am.
You know, and if I go into a studio
and if I find my truth of the moment,
there are a number of people in the world
that can relate to what I'm saying
and is going to buy into what I'm doing.
You know, not because it's
the new thing of the moment,
but because it's my genuine emotions,
it's how I feel.
This is how I articulate the world.
And you know, just having
the discipline to you know,
be yourself.